distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the Nobel week
dialogue I think we can promise a day
full of excitement that will stimulate
your thinking and imagination Alfred
Nobel had high ambitions for his price
he wanted the prices that bear his name
to contribute to the greatest benefit of
mankind today we are doing this by
organizing the first Nobel week dialogue
the 20th century when people look back
from many centuries from now will
clearly be known as the information
century because it turned out quite
unexpectedly to those at the beginning
of the 20th century that life was
fundamentally about information that
information was encoded in organisms I
end with a quote by a moccasin what
should keep us awake at night the
tragedies that we can prevent the
injustice that we can repair thank you
what was the thinking behind writing the
double helix okay two girls I would tell
them the story you know to try and make
myself interesting to them sup you're
right this the story was
within a year of writing the book you've
got married no no no I mean yeah within
a month of its publication we got
married
so it worked yeah we're still married 45
years ago so it was a enormous success
we've been modifying plants and animals
for over 4,000 years most people put a
lot of harm to GMOs which are not caused
by GMOs at all welcome to panel to a
witch in which we're going to discuss
genetics in agriculture in the
environment what are the pros and cons
of genetic modification we're going to
need to produce about seventy percent
more food than we have today one of the
main problems is to be generalized too
much about GM crops and I think what we
should do as scientists is explained
exactly these details so the issue of
risk in other ways really has to be
communicated in a much more detailed
fashion how many of you would like to
have your genome sequenced this is about
scissors sixty percent he's an optimist
joe says thirty to forty percent so I
think 55
in Russia India China Brazil South
Africa there's been on average about a
two hundred percent increase in a number
of clinical trials that are now going
out in the developing well and let them
decide their own risk they're the ones
that have cancer not us if they want to
higher dose and are aware of the risks
why not give it to them yeah how far
does that go Bert I mean should should
we just then make those drugs available
without approval at all because if they
want it they should be entitled to no no
of course not so this is a general
question that's shared by the online
audience from Mumbai to Massachusetts is
it possible to silence an extra
chromosome at an embryonic level or even
simply repress the expression of a gene
to prevent the manifestation of diseases
and syndromes can we make our DNA repair
system more powerful we have a question
from a med student in Israel so he's
asking what kind of drugs do you think
we're going to have in the future do you
think that the media supports your work
and the process towards the market or
would you say it slows down
I thought today's conference was
fantastic I think it's a wonderful
opportunity for people in the community
to talk and have a dialogue about really
important scientific issues that are
impacting all of mankind's it's really
interesting way to find out what two top
people in this field of thinking about
and I enjoyed talking with the other
people on the panel and exchanging our
views and I learned a lot while we're
certainly stimulating I thought the most
exciting part was certainly the dialogue
I thought there were a lot of wonderful
ideas a lot of very smart people sort of
getting together exchanging ideas unless
you have a dialogue when people can ask
each other questions you miss that key
aspect of science it's very different to
normally scientific conferences where
it's actually only scientists I think
it's very important to have all sorts of
different participants Nobel laureate
scientists as well as students and
general public because what we often
don't do is reach out to the public it's
been really encouraging to see how
scientists can engage the public in
these important discussions about
science related topics it brings down
science to the level where everybody
could discuss and actually help spread
the message of science the scientists
have to do a better job of educating the
public we've reached the point where it
is the difference between whether we
deliver on the scientific promise or
whether we have to explain to our
children why we fail what is going to
cure some cancers some combination of
new therapies immunotherapies perhaps
gene therapies and mistero therapies
mistero therapy is mysterious therapy
that has yet to be invented now who is
going to invent it it's going to be this
people like in this audience the young
people because only those people don't
yet know what won't work we senior
investigators know what won't work so we
don't try it when you give young
scientists the power to pursue their
ideas and their curiosity wonderful
things happen bringing together social
scientists life scientists medical
professionals young people i think it
was wonderful its format in general i
think is unique
it was definitely worth continuing
you